TANYA: Thanks,
everybody, for coming.
My first interaction with Eric
at the recent Wildlife Center
Summit was-- there was a speaker
speaking about technology
to help rhinos for
rhino conservation.
And he was correcting a speaker
while they were talking.
And every few minutes, he
had a more official statistic
to give to this speaker.
And I was like,
this guy is amazing.
He really knows his rhinos.
So I'd like to welcome
Dr. Eric Dinerstein.
He's the Director of the
Biodiversity and Wildlife
Solutions Program at RESOLVE.
He focuses on applying
new technologies
to better protect and
monitor endangered wildlife.
For much of the
past 25 years, he
was the Chief Scientist at
the World Wildlife Fund.
Beginning in 1975,
he conducted studies
of tigers and their prey,
and led conservation programs
for large mammals, such as
greater one-horned rhinoceros
and tigers with the
National Zoo's Terai Ecology
Project in Nepal.
Along with Dr. David Olson,
he's the Co-Architect
of the Global 200 Terrestrial
Eco Regions of the world.
And Dr. Eric Wikramanayake,
mapped tiger conservation
landscapes, designed
the Terai Arc Landscape
in Nepal and India, and came up
with the idea of a Global Tiger
Summit staged in November
2010 to double the wild tiger
population in the world.
He has conservation
experience in many countries
and has published
wildly and widely
on biodiversity, eco regions,
and large mammal biology.
His most recent effort is to
promote the concept popularized
by Dr. E.O. Wilson
of Nature Needs Half,
setting aside half of the
earth's terrestrial eco regions
to save a living planet
and avoid the extinction
and climate crises.
He's published over a hundred
papers in scientific journals
and has co-authored
several books
on conservation
assessments of eco regions
around the world,
a scientific book
on rhinos, two
popular science books.
And most recently, a novel
for children and adults
called "What Elephants Know."
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Eric Dinerstein to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC DINERSTEIN: Thank
you so much, Tanya.
And it's great to be here.
What I'm going to try
to do in my short talk
is to give you a
sense of what it
was like to be-- a long
time ago-- 21 years old
and to be sent to the
wildest place on earth.
And to have the adventure
of my lifetime, which I
tried to capture in this novel.
And also, to make all
of you tiger experts.
I'm going to condense 45
years of tiger research
into about five minutes.
So you're going to
leave here knowing more
about tigers than 99% of all
the biologists in the world.
And then also, for those
of you who have not
gotten a PhD in
conservation biology,
I'm going to summarize
the whole discipline
in about two sentences.
So I'll save you that heartache,
too, of getting a new degree.
So in 1975, I had the
unbelievable good luck,
good fortune, of being sent
to the country of Nepal.
The kingdom of
Nepal at the time.
And I got my information packet.
And in it was information--
and I loved the idea of Nepal.
I had just finished my
undergraduate degree.
And I loved-- it was
in Washington state.
And I loved climbing mountains.
And I thought, fantastic.
I'm going to Nepal, the
country of Mount Everest.
I'll live with Sherpas.
I'll study Tibetan Buddhism,
and maybe I'll never come back.
And then I got the
information packet.
And in it were
pictures of things
like elephants, and
tigers, and rhinos.
And I knew enough
about biogeography
to know that, oh, these probably
don't live in the Himalayas.
They are flat-land
creatures, for the most part.
Although, tigers do go up to
timberline in some places.
But I wasn't prepared
that I was actually
going to a part of Nepal
that I didn't know existed
called the Terai,
the flat lowlands.
It's the extension
of the Gangetic Plain
that is only 600 feet elevation.
And this gives
you a sense of it.
So here it is.
This is from
Chitwan, but this is
sort of like to where
Bardiya where I was sent,
with the elephant grasses.
This is about 600
feet elevation.
These are the world's
tallest grasslands.
They get to be 25 feet tall.
So you need elephants
to get through them
or you walk
carefully, either way.
And then behind it, Mount
Annapurna at 26,000 feet
collapsed in only
about 60 miles.
So this is probably the only
place in the world you can be
sitting on an elephant with
a rhino in front of you with
26,000-foot peaks
in the background.
And I thought somehow if I
could capture this experience,
it would be great.
But mostly, I
wrote in a journal.
Getting out here was
really interesting.
It was 1975.
There was no road
across lowland Nepal.
And so we tried taking
a Jeep on dirt tracks.
And the monsoon had
just started when most
of the rain of the year falls.
And we got about 10
miles towards the reserve
and we got stuck in a river,
had to winch our way out.
So we tried a different
route, got stuck again
in another river, and
had to winch our way out.
And we just gave up and
said, you know what?
Let's go back to the main city.
You're going to have to wait for
your vehicle to get you there.
It's going to be an elephant.
So I went on a 50-mile trek on
an elephant to get to my post.
And one of the reasons why I
called the book "What Elephants
Know--" the novel-- is that
I'm convinced that elephants
know a lot more than people
about a lot of things
in the world.
And one of them was when we
got to the edge of a river
like this, except it was a
flooding torrent with trees
coming down, like toothpicks
washing down the river.
I knew this probably wasn't
a good idea to try to cross.
But the drivers were in a
hurry to drop me off and get
back home to their stable.
And so they kept
pushing the elephant.
The way you drive
an elephant is you
kick behind the ears, which
is like the gas pedal.
And they kept driving it,
driving it into the water.
And this is an older female.
And she didn't want to go in.
She tried to shake us off,
but they kept pushing.
And she was up to her toenails,
and then up to her elbows.
And then, up to her shoulders.
In the next instant,
we were swept away.
Next slide.
It's going much
faster than that.
And that wasn't my
elephant, but just
to remember what it was like.
It turns out we had
crossed in the wrong place.
Elephants, fortunately,
are very good swimmers.
Very buoyant.
So she swam back to shore.
We got out.
And I asked some locals.
They said, oh, yeah.
You crossed in the wrong place.
You should have gone up here.
And wait till the sun rises
higher and the river level
will go down and you can cross.
So I made it.
I got to my post, and then
had the greatest adventure
of my life.
And I thought, well,
somehow if I could hark back
to that first experience
of trying to get to my post
and put that in a novel, it
might be a fun story to tell.
As well, the way that I
studied-- my assignment
was really one sentence from
the head of the National Park
system in Nepal.
You will go and you will
census the tiger population
and do other wildlife
surveys as is necessary.
And this park,
called Bardiya-- now
called Bardiya National Park--
was first a royal hunting
reserve for the king.
And one of the places set up
a newly created tiger reserve.
And I was the first
biologist to go out there.
And probably, the
first Westerner
to live in this area
for a long time.
And Nepal had been closed to
the West for about 100 years.
And the way that I was going
to try to census tigers
was to take pictures of them.
Because as you'll
see in a moment,
you can tell them apart
by stripes on their bodies
and other patterns.
And the way to do
that would be to be
out in the jungle at dawn and
dusk and take pictures of them.
And be above them where
they couldn't detect you.
And at least 15
feet above them so
they wouldn't try to
climb the tree after you.
So over the course of-- I
built a number of tree houses
with the locals helping me.
About 13 of these scattered
along roads on routes
that tigers would take.
Tigers are highly territorial.
And they like to
mark their territory.
So the idea was if you were on
the place where tigers marked,
you would be able to
take their pictures.
So in the course of
spending two years there,
I spent over 120
nights in tree houses
so I could be there to
take their pictures.
And I guess in some way,
I became the Peace Corps
first semi-arboreal volunteer.
Sometimes though, when I
woke up, I would see this.
A tiger below me
tracking the deer
or stalking and
trying to catch them.
And here was one of the
species they were after.
This is a swamp deer, a
highly endangered species,
that is only-- there's
probably about 5,000
left in a couple of parks,
but is an important prey item
for deer.
So one of the first-- I'm
going to condense tiger biology
in a very short amount of time.
Tigers go after large prey.
They need that to survive.
The swamp deer is the
ultimate tiger species.
If tigers had the menu,
like you have out here,
of all the different
species they could eat,
they would always pick swamp
deer because they're big
and they occur in
really big herds.
And they're easier to catch.
There just aren't
that many of them,
so they eat other
kinds of things
that we'll see in a second.
I didn't have the
chance to actually
live around elephants the
first time because there
were no elephants in Bardiya.
I did everything on foot.
But when I came back later
to work with the Smithsonian,
we had five elephants at our
disposal for doing research.
And I got to live with the
drivers, learned the 40
different elephant commands,
how to drive the elephants,
how to utter the commands.
Everything from [? agat, ?]
which means go forward.
And the most important one,
[? rat, ?] which means stop.
Because you have to get them
to stop sometimes if they get
scared.
So I learned those.
It was such a fascinating
and now declining
culture of elephant
husbandry and living
near elephant stables
that I wanted to make
that part of the book as well.
This is Dr. John
Seidensticker, the Dean
of Tiger Biologists in 1972.
He looks a bit like Indiana
Jones in this picture,
but it's a little
different nowadays.
He's retired now.
But this was the first
captured tigeress--
the first radio-collared
tiger in Chitwan
that I was fortunate
enough to help out
on this study in the early days.
And it kind of whetted my
appetite for tiger research.
But also, for now
applying technology.
So this is the first time that
radio telemetry was really
being introduced in
a big way into Asia.
And the important thing we
learned from this research
is that tigers are
highly territorial.
And they have-- in areas
with very high prey density,
like in Chitwan, here they
have the smallest home ranges
of tigers anywhere
in the world, where
tigers can live in an area
of about 20 square kilometers
and keep other males out.
And within his home
range, there may
be four females that will
have their own territories
and won't intersect at all.
And he'll surround those.
Now, that's at one
end of the extreme.
The other is the Russian Far
East with much, much more lower
prey densities, where a same
male tiger would have a home
range of 600 square kilometers.
So you get a sense of it
takes a lot of habitat
to maintain a healthy
population of tigers
when they're territorial.
So one of the
things though, that
happened when I first moved
there and worked in Nepal,
is that the reason why these
tiger reserves were sent up
is because they were hunting
reserves for the royal family.
So the kings of Nepal used
to come and shoot tigers
annually in the parks.
And the quid pro quo for us is
they did set up these parks.
And the rest of the year--
they only took one or two--
the tigers would recover.
And so they were
doing quite well.
But I thought this was
such an interesting part
that I timed my book to be in
1975 during one of these tiger
hunts.
And I'm going to just
introduce the book to you.
The character, my
protagonist, is a young boy
who is only 12 years old.
And with some homage
to the "Jungle Book,"
he was found in the
jungle not by wolves,
but by a pack of wild
dogs, called [? dole. ?]
And cared for them
for a very short time
until he's found by the head
of an elephant stable who
has only one arm, who
lost it in a fight
with a tiger, who finds him in
the jungle and brings him back
and raises him as his own son.
And they're about to go
on-- he's now 11 years old
and he's going on the hunt with
the king to go after a tiger.
Chapter 1.
"My mother is an
elephant and my father
is an old man with one arm.
Strange, I know, but true.
For a short time, I was under
the care of [? dole, ?] wild
dogs that live in the jungle.
Before the [? dole, ?] I had
a different mother and father
who tied a red
string around my neck
and left me alone in the world.
They believed the red string
would give me protection.
I do not know what became of
them or why they abandoned me.
My father is the
head of an elephant
stable in the southernmost
part of Nepal.
He is called Subba-sahib,
a title of great respect
that everyone
uses, including me.
The older drivers also
call him Old One Arm,
but never to his face.
I also call him Father,
but only inside my head.
For 50 years, our
elephant stable
has been maintained by
order of the King of Nepal.
Also, that once a year
the King and his family
can ride into the jungle on
our elephants to hunt tigers.
The stable exists
in the borderlands,
a region far from
Kathmandu, the capital city.
Our camp is at the edge
of the forest, where
tall trees and dense vines
push right up to our stable.
Our jungle is wild,
beautiful, and dangerous,
filled with rhinos, tigers,
leopards, crocodiles, snakes,
and every kind of bird.
I have learned to be wary of
wild animals, but never afraid.
The sight of 100 elephants
gathered together,
trumpeting, rumbling,
and snorting
to each other filled
everyone with excitement
to ride elephants and
hunt tigers with the King.
For many, today would be
the most adventurous day
of their lives.
At last, the trio of
elephants began to move.
We crossed the [INAUDIBLE]
River by the stable
and headed off into the jungle.
It would be a half hour's march
West towards the great Sandbar
River to reach the Western
edge of the borderlands.
The familiar swaying movement of
my body riding Devi Kali-- that
was the name of his elephant
and his adopted mother--
and the sound of branches
breaking under her feet
calmed my nerves.
When you ride an elephant,
you are a king, no matter
your rank in the world.
I was deep in thought when
a monkey screeched above us,
making the government
official on my elephant jump.
I looked up into
the tall fig tree,
trying to keep from
making a sound.
A trio of monkeys sat
together eating figs,
watching us march
under their world.
We entered a large,
open area in the jungle,
and I leaned over to look
for tiger tracks in the sand.
The sun had climbed
higher in the sky,
and its warmth felt good
on my wet shoulders.
We were 10 elephants
behind the King,
who rode on my father's lead
elephant, the great tusker
named [? Bim Prasad. ?]
Every time the elephant
turned his head,
his huge ivory tusks
glowed like crescent moons
in the morning sun.
I looked back to see the long
ribbon of elephants following.
It struck me then
how lucky I was
to be the only 11-year-old
boy in Nepal, perhaps the only
11-year-old boy ever, to ride in
the hunting party of the King.
When we reached the
river's main channel,
we crossed over to the islands
where the tall, thin Rosewood
trees stood staring at us.
My father turned to me.
His look told me that
he had picked up a sign.
I stood on Devi Kali again and
saw the fresh track of a tiger
in the sand along the beach.
I could clearly make out
its great footprints.
If you rested a
man's hat on one,
the print would
barely be covered.
My father nodded
to us and pointed
to where he thought
the tiger was hiding.
He steered [? Bim Prasad ?] to
position his majesty for his
shot, and signaled our driver,
[? Ramji, ?] to move Devi Kali
just behind them.
I saw the government official
smile for the first time
that morning, pleased to be
stationed so close to the king.
We were near enough that I
could hear my father whisper,
the tiger's tracks lead
into that patch of grass.
We will wait here.
When I give the signal, my
team will drive the tiger out.
You will need to take your
shot quickly, Your Majesty.
King [? Virendra ?] nodded.
My father waved his arm and
70 elephants with their riders
quietly fanned out to encircle
the tiger's hiding place.
The government official
licked his lips
and kept his eyes
on the clearing,
as if he were the one
readying to take his shot.
My father handed
the King his rifle.
I silently prayed
to the jungle gods
that his majesty would miss.
My father whistled, signaling
for the elephants and drivers
to start shouting
and banging sticks
to drive the tiger
from its hiding spot.
The tops of the tall grasses
swayed back and forth,
from the breeze or the moving
elephants or the moving tiger,
we could not tell.
The grass hid even the heads
of the spotters standing
on the backs of the elephants.
A sudden roar sent two of the
younger elephants squealing
in panic into the forest, their
drivers and riders bouncing
helplessly on their backs.
I wanted to tell
the official that he
was lucky to be on my Devi
Kali who never flinched,
but I kept silent.
Suddenly, a tiger of
at least 300 pounds
leapt into the open
area and stopped.
The King hesitated, and
then raised his rifle.
The animal turned.
And right away, I recognized
the one we called [? Tutchi. ?]
Instead of shutting my eyes,
as my father had told me,
I leaped up and hurled
my small hand ax
straight at the tigress, and
shouted at the top of my voice,
run, [? Tutchi, ?] run."
And I'll stop there.
So you have to
read it if you want
to know what happens to him.
OK.
So back with real tigers.
So we've learned so much
about their biology.
And when I finished my
PhD, I had the great chance
of coming back to Nepal with
the Smithsonian Institution
to lead the Tiger Ecology
Project where we studied
rhinos as well as tigers.
So another first.
This is us in 1996
capturing the first greater
one-horned rhinoceros.
And here, we have attached
the blue belt is a radio
collar, where we learned a
great deal about their behavior
as well.
This is not a dead tiger.
It's a live tiger
that's been immobilized.
So people think that the
largest tigers in the world
live in the Russian Far East.
The so-called Siberian tigers.
They're all one species.
But that's not true.
The largest tigers
in the world live
in the parts of where
this novel takes
place in the Nepalese Terai.
This male that we captured was
over-- we couldn't weigh it.
It was over the
weight of our scales.
It was at least 560 pounds.
So the tigers in
the Siberian part--
it's not really Siberia,
but the Russian Far East.
They're just bigger and fluffier
because they live in the snow.
But if you took the body
mass of the males on average,
the ones in this part of
Nepal in Northern India
are much bigger than-- or
bigger than the ones in Russia.
So you can get a sense--
they are the world's largest
predators.
And this one, you can
see just for scale.
There are three Nepalese behind
trying to hold the head up.
Now, what they eat.
This is not a good idea.
So here's another
piece of technology.
You can see the
infrared camera trap
in the middle there taking the
picture of this tiger closing
in on an Asian or
Indian porcupine.
It looks very similar to
the African porcupine.
And often, when tigers
become-- the rare times
they become man-eaters,
it's because they
have attacked a
porcupine and get shot up
in their paws and jaws with
quills and can't get them out
and can't feed.
So a better choice-- and this
is not a good one either.
This is a tiger
with a sloth bear.
The sloth bears also
figure into my novel.
You'll read about
them if you read it.
Very aggressive bear that
either comes right at you
or runs away.
They live on termites and
ants and honey and fruit.
But you can see
the claws on them.
They're quite ferocious.
This is a better choice
of food for the tiger.
This is the sambar,
the Indian forest deer.
And this is the
right-sized body shape
and less aggressive
as a prey item.
So tigers feed
mostly on swamp deer.
On sambar deer
across their range.
And they need to eat-- a
breeding female tigress needs
to eat about one sambar a week,
or something equivalent in body
mass to be able to reproduce.
So that's a very important
piece of tiger biology
that we learned in the
course of this work.
Less than that and
they won't breed.
They'll still stay
alive, but they
need that much energy
to produce more tigers.
Just to give you a sense of
scale to how big tigers are,
I just found this on the web.
Somebody took this recently
in one of the Indian parks.
But here's a leopard
in comparison
with the size of the tiger.
One of the things
we've learned too
is that where tigers
are really dense,
leopards tend to be scarce.
So leopards tend to occupy more
of the edges of tiger ranges
and areas close to
villages because they
eat a wide variety of things.
Leopards could live on
small birds, rodents
if they had to,
where a tiger never
could eat anything smaller
than pretty much a wild boar
and still be breeding.
But you can see the tremendous
size difference there.
Tigers have declined
dramatically
across their range.
The biologist that I
showed the picture of,
Dr. John Seidensticker,
early on in 1972,
he was sitting in
my office about--
oh, about eight years ago.
And I said, John,
what we're doing
is not working for tigers.
Their numbers are going down.
We thought there were
probably no more than 3,200
left in the wild.
To put that in
perspective, there
is more tigers alive in private
hands in the state of Texas
than there is in the wild.
And so we thought, OK, what
are the two things that we
need to do to try and
dramatically recover the tiger
population?
And one is to get
support of government
at the highest levels,
the heads of state.
And then, to
mobilize an order of
magnitude more resources
for tiger conservation.
So we came up with the idea
for the first-ever Global Tiger
Summit, which was
hosted by Vladimir Putin
back in the days when
he was the good Vladimir
Putin in Saint Petersburg.
And we had the heads of state
of the 13 tiger range states.
Most of them had come.
And sign a declaration to
double the number of wild tigers
by 2022, which is the
next year of the tiger.
So 2010 was the year of the
tiger in the Chinese calendar.
'22, the next year of the tiger.
So the idea was in 12 years, to
try and go from 3,200 to 6,500
across the range.
And so that became
shortened to instead
of double the wild tiger
population between 2010
to 2022 as T times 2, a
shorthand, which people
have now bought into.
And we've made
remarkable progress.
So tigers and wolves--
another very important point
of tiger biology-- are
the two top predators
that can breed as fast or
faster than their prey.
So if there's enough prey there,
like the sambar, the wild boar,
that are out there for--
swamp deer for tigers to eat.
They can potentially
have a litter every year
with four to five cubs in it.
So they can recover
very quickly.
Tigers are basically
very big cats
that just breed like crazy.
They give them
contraceptives in zoos
to keep them from breeding.
So if we just protect their
habitat, provide enough prey,
stop the poaching,
they come roaring back.
And that's basically
what we've found.
This is a totally
gratuitous slide.
Nothing to do with
the rest of my topic,
I just love these [INAUDIBLE].
They're not even crocodiles.
They're ancient
crocodilians that
also live in where
this novel takes place.
It was one of the last
strongholds of the world.
There's only a few places
left where they live.
They get to be 20 feet long.
They only eat fish,
so you don't have
to worry about them,
like Nile crocodiles.
Back to the tigers.
So if we are able to
protect enough area,
then we can see this doubling.
And I'll get to how we're
tracking that in a moment.
The same thing is true with
rhinos that I was studying,
is their population-- there's
about 2,900 individuals left.
There's five species of rhinos,
about 25,000 left in the world.
They are under tremendous
pressure from poachers.
But Nepal has done an
unbelievably magnificent job
of protecting their tigers,
elephants, and rhinos.
In the last three
years, there has not
been a single one
poached in Nepal.
And tiger numbers have gone up
by 61% in the last five years
from the two
censuses we've done.
Rhinos by 31%.
In India, the tigers have
gone up by 30% as well.
So in some countries, we're
making tremendous progress
on our goal towards T times 2.
One of the species that's
not doing very well,
this is the Sumatran rhino,
the second most endangered
large mammal in the world.
The first being the [INAUDIBLE].
There's probably only
100 left scattered
around parts of Sumatra.
This is one that's
a few days old.
They're very primitive
rhinos, the most ancient.
These are kind of hairy-like
coconuts when they are born.
They had this shaggy fur.
They had been bred in
captivity in a Cincinnati Zoo.
Unfortunately, where they had
the gorilla that was killed.
But the only zoo that's
been able to breed them
through artificial insemination.
And the strategy
here for a species
like this where there are so few
is to bring them all together,
so they can breed.
And we just produce more babies
than are dying in A short time
to be able to try to save them.
So a lot of my work at
Biodiversity and Wildlife
Solutions is trying--
and how I first met
Tanya is our work through
this Google-organized group
of wildlife centers.
And coming up with applying new
technologies to save endangered
wildlife.
So I'm going to talk to you
a little bit about that right
now.
We're working in Africa
with a number of groups
to try to address head-on
the poaching crisis.
With elephants, we have
lost 100,000 elephants
over the last five years.
That's one fifth of the
population of wild elephants
in a relatively short time.
They're going to
disappear in the Congo
basin and other places unless
we are able to stop poachers
before they kill.
There's a lot of
effort placed on,
what do we do with
like tracking the ivory
or shutting down demand?
And that's all
critically important.
But we have to be able to
stop the poachers before they
get to the animals
in the first place.
And there's a number
of technologies
we're working on that have
the promise to do that.
I'm just going to
show you-- so there's
two parts to the aspect
of saving elephants.
And one is to stop the poaching.
And the other is that
elephants are moving into--
are living in habitats
that they always lived in
and people are moving into them.
So they're disrupting
traditional migration routes
and habitats of the elephants.
And they're planting
crops there.
So the other big
problem to solve--
and in fact, if you talk to most
heads of state of governments
or national parks
departments, they'll
tell you our biggest
problem is not poaching.
It's human-elephant conflict.
Of elephants coming
into crop lands,
destroying crops, killing
people, antagonizing everybody,
and then making
them very unwelcome.
We all love elephants
in our country.
But if you went to
Tanzania or Kenya
and talked to a
roomful of villagers,
they would not be very
happy about the presence
of elephants.
So how can we resolve that?
Well, one is-- I'm going
to get to in a second,
is using drones to scare
elephants out of croplands.
But another aspect
of the poaching
is that because of
poachers being detected
by shooting elephants
with high-powered weapons,
they've gone back to the
traditional approach of killing
elephants by shooting
them with poison arrows.
And then, tracking them
for days as the elephants
wear down and die.
It's just horribly cruel.
And then, hack out the tusks.
Hack out the ivory and move on.
This was the case of an
elephant in the Mara, part
of the northern extension
of the Serengeti,
with our colleagues and
partners, the Mara Elephant
Project, that was hit by
several poison arrows.
And how we used
drones that we're
using to drive elephants out
of croplands in a creative way
to save this elephant's life.
So let's watch this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-My name is Mark
[? Golson. ?] I'll
be narrating this short film.
Here we see a
wounded bull elephant
crossing the Mara River.
We were able to treat
him some days later.
Here is a [? quadcopter ?]
David [? Olsen ?] gave me.
We used this machine to move
the same bull elephant out
of a water [INAUDIBLE]
some three weeks later.
We wanted to treat him again.
ERIC DINERSTEIN: He
probably has a high fever,
so he's staying in
the water to cool off.
It was too dangerous to
go on foot to get him.
-So that the vet could dart him.
Here he is moving along
the water [INAUDIBLE].
We were able to move
him into an open area.
And this part of the
operation was a success.
The [? M99 ?] took eight
minutes to start taking effect.
Now, the bull is going to sleep.
The [INAUDIBLE]
vet team was then
able to move in to
start the treatment.
Dr. [? Linmore ?]
examines the elephant.
We actually have
a metal detector
to check for any
foreign objects.
And here comes the arrowhead.
It actually took three
weeks to move right the way
across his leg.
Dr. [? Linmore ?]
flushes out the wound.
After administering antibiotics
and the reversal drug,
the elephant was
up and on his way.
This operation was
made easier by the use
of the $500 [? quadcopter. ?]
[END PLAYBACK]
ERIC DINERSTEIN: So
that rescue actually
was a spin-off, an
unintended consequence,
of using drones to drive
elephants out of croplands.
This elephant may be
thinking, oh my god, that's
the world's largest tsetse
fly, or whatever he's thinking.
But he's alert.
But in the next second,
he's about to run.
What we have been doing over
the last year and a half,
we've now sent an
article [INAUDIBLE]
the journal "Oryx"
for publication,
of using low-cost,
easy-to-maneuver,
easy-to-train [? Rangers ?]
drones, the DJI phantom,
the same model that went over
into the White House lawn
that banned drone flying in
the D.C. area for some time.
[INAUDIBLE] at a certain radius.
That we've been using this
to drive elephants out
of croplands.
And the litmus test is
driving them out at night
when they're already in
the maize fields feeding.
Because just during the
daytime like this is great,
but the real test is when
they're destroying crops.
The results are sort
of unbelievable.
As a scientist,
we've done 51 trials.
And we've had 100% success rate.
Within 20 seconds, the
elephants turn and run.
And we have great
videos of-- which
I won't show now, but of
herds being driven away back
into a national park
over several kilometers
by this little, tiny $500 drone.
If the drones themselves
don't scare them, attach
the very high-tech device
at the bottom of the drone
is a plastic bag full of chili
powder with holes poked in it.
And we just jiggle the drone
and out comes the chili powder.
And they hate the
smell of chili.
And that drives them away.
We haven't had to use that yet.
But the reason we think
this is so effective
is that the propellers
make a sound very
similar to the frequency of
swarming angry bees or hornets.
And elephants have this
out-sized fear of bees.
It's not mice they're scared of.
It's bees.
Maybe they're afraid
they'll fly up their trunks
or in their ears, but I think
this is genetically hardwired.
We don't think they're going
to get habituated to this,
but we'll see.
But we've done this now for
two different crop seasons.
And it's we're incredibly well.
So we're now trying to scale
this to other parts of Africa.
Where we're going
next in two more weeks
is to Tsavo National Park.
He mentioned, Mark [? Gos, ?]
the Sheldrick Trust.
We're working with
them to deploy
these anti-poaching devices.
So one of the
things-- as I said,
we have to stop poachers
before they kill.
All of the devices, the camera
traps that are out there.
These kind of big, bulky boxes
that are above the ground.
They can be camouflaged,
but sharp-eyed poachers
can find them and smash them.
Elephants will smash them.
Our device is a
little, tiny unit
that is simply above ground.
And the rest of it is hidden
away either underground or up
in the tree.
But this can be hidden in a
fake vine in a rain forest.
Or you'll see in a
second, where we do it.
And it sends an
image of the poacher.
It has human detection
algorithms in it.
And sends out either
satellite, cell,
or through a long-range radio
frequency to the headquarters.
This is actually
smaller than this now,
but this was the
first prototype.
This is just the camera head.
It's as big as your thumb
that sits above ground,
but that's cryptic and hidden.
And then, there's a
passive infrared beam here.
It's broken, wakes
up the camera.
It takes the pictures,
and then sends them all.
Only those though,
that are humans
so that we save
energy and battery
life of not just
sending branches,
or birds, or other creatures.
So I'm going to
ask you now, where
do you think that
camera head is hidden?
This is the interactive
part of my talk.
So is it here?
Is it in this knot?
Or in this knot?
How many you vote for here?
Raise your hands.
How about here?
OK, it's a trick question.
None of those.
It's right there.
So the point being that you
could walk-- even really
sharp-eyed poachers would
probably walk by this.
And they're pretty much
going by dusk or evening
and they won't be
able to find it.
So it's totally cryptic.
The rest of the computer
is hidden down here.
Don't feel bad, because even
these Kenya Wildlife Service
rangers couldn't find it either.
So we demoed this last summer.
And now, with a new
version is going out there
that we're ready to
go to scale with this.
The other device that we
have is called AmbushCam.
So all those rangers, they
told us most of what we do
is we protect-- we go after
poachers by sending ambushes.
We get some intelligence.
We're just not
wandering aimlessly.
And the idea here is
that being on an ambush
is really dangerous.
And also, really boring because
they could be for hours or days
on end on the trail waiting
for poachers to come down.
Our new idea of AmbushCam is you
put the eyeballs on the trail.
So we have the passive
infrared sensor here.
We have a flare [INAUDIBLE]
camera here that
streams the video
to rangers who are
off the trail in their bivouac,
probably not talking loudly,
but they could be
eating, sleeping.
One ranger is on duty.
And he's wearing
these goggles that
have an earpiece in
them that sends a beep
if the beam is broken.
And then, streaming video
to see how many poachers
are coming down the trail.
And they can then
set the ambush.
As a spin-off of
that, we've also
created the world's
cheapest night
vision goggles that we can
make, we think, for about $400.
Rather than the sort
of $3,000 to $4,000
that military-grade night
vision goggles go for.
With the idea being
that every ranger that
is out on night patrols to
protect wildlife in Africa
should be-- a standard equipment
should have these cheap night
vision goggles.
So we're taking those over
now to do one more prototype.
And we hope to go into
production-- [EXPLOSION].
The other idea-- if we want
to go more militaristic--
is a very heavily-armed
group of poachers come down
with AK-47's, either you
can just let them go.
Or the next passive
infrared sensor
could then remotely trigger
a flashbang stun grenade.
And then, disarm the poachers.
Because typically,
the rangers tell us
you often only catch
one of the poachers
because the rest run away.
This way, you'd be able
to-- where you're allowed
to do this-- immobilize them.
And then, safely disarm
them and arrest them.
So what we're trying
to do though--
and this is a friend of ours.
One of our donors at the David
Sheldrick Wildlife Trust.
Those of you who know
of this in Kenya,
near Nairobi National Park,
they have an elephant orphanage.
These are all young
elephants whose mothers
have been poached.
And they take them there,
raise them, resocialize them,
and reintroduce them.
We're working with
the Sheldrick Trust
on their anti-poaching side.
This is the first place
we're deploying them widely
with the trail guards and ambush
cams and night vision googles,
with the idea of not
making any more orphans.
So that's really our mission.
Very quickly, I'm just going
to talk about two more things.
So one is about--
back to tigers,
is the fate of tigers is tied
up with humans, of course.
In India, we have 60% of the
world's tigers living amidst
a billion people.
And how do we configure
the landscapes
so that we can leave
space for tigers
and leave space
for humans as well?
So part of our study
that we're doing
that's powered by Google Earth
Engine published in "Science
Advances" last
April, was a paper
called "Tracking Changes
and Preventing Loss
in Critical Tiger Habitat."
So these are the 76 tiger
conservation landscapes
scattered across Southeast
Asia and the Russian Far
East in an inset here.
And the 76 are scored
either as what we call T
times 2, TCLs or non-T times 2.
Meaning the ones in
magenta here are the ones
that are going to contribute
most to doubling the wild tiger
population in 12 years.
They have the healthiest,
largest populations.
What we can do using Google
Earth Engine and the data
from Matt [? Hansen ?]
is to track changes
in the habitat of tigers.
Because to get to
T times 2, we need
to have a certain
amount of habitat.
Because tigers are territorial,
different size territories.
How much area do we
need to set aside
to be able to protect them?
And what we found, the
results were remarkable.
Over the 14 year period, we
expected a tremendous amount
of loss of habitat.
Because these are the
fastest-growing economies
in the world, high
rural population
densities in India, Nepal,
Bangladesh, and a few others.
We've only lost about
7% of the tiger habitat
over this 14-year period.
We thought it would
be more like 21%.
So that's a really
great finding.
Equally important is there
is still enough habitat
left in the tiger range
to allow for not only
a doubling of wild tigers,
but almost even a tripling.
Which we only found out because
of the value of Google Earth
Engine and Global Forest Watch
to be able to compute this,
which we couldn't
do two years ago.
So we're now doing-- to show
this can work at the Terai Arc
landscape where-- my book
takes place right here.
We're going to zoom in on a
couple of these corridors.
So another critical important
piece of tiger biology,
tigers have to-- male
tigers have to disperse.
They can't stay in
their natal home range
or the adult male
will kill them.
And tigers are relatively
poor dispersers,
unlike, say, wolves.
So you have to have relatively
interconnected forest
corridors for tigers to
go from A to B to C to D.
So we can use the new
approach we have to zoom in.
This is really the
most-- not only
look at the whole scale
of the tiger habitat
and look at changes
annually, but move in
and look at changes in
these critical corridors.
And to show that
here in this one,
in the [? Basanta ?]
Corridor, we've actually lost
habitat here in this critical
connector piece right here.
And here in the
[? Kata ?] Corridor,
we've actually
gained habitat, which
you can see not so well here.
But there's a
number-- right here.
Yeah, these blue polygons here
are where community forestry
programs have helped reestablish
connectivity with India.
The tigers in this park
have gone from 18 to 50
in the last five years.
In part because of
better protection,
but also because of movement
back and forth from India.
So we have a whole new
tool at our disposal
now to better manage tigers.
And look across which
of the 76 landscapes
are the ones that
have lost the most
amount of absolute habitat.
And what percent of it?
And now, the tiger range
states-- most important--
they're using this as
their monitoring tool
to measure progress
towards conserving that.
We're just about to receive a
grant this week from the Arcus
Foundation in working with
the Jane Goodall Institute
to do the same analysis
for African and Asian apes
in the next year.
So very useful way
of looking at that.
And now, I'm going to
end with just saving you
the heartache of going and
doing a PhD in conservation
biology at Stanford, say.
I'm going to reduce conservation
biology into one sentence.
One phrase, even.
Pay attention to the
landscapes and beta-diversity.
So the first part was--
I showed you on tigers
and the apes is-- some
of the critical species
we have to save, you
need to take a landscape
approach to conservation.
That protected areas by
themselves are too small.
There's not a single
protected area
in the entire tiger
range large enough
to maintain a viable population.
So what you need to do is
to have linked reserves
where tigers are managed as a
meta-population, a population
linked by dispersal.
That's what we have to do at
one extreme for what we call
"area-sensitive species."
Tigers, elephants,
jaguars, et cetera.
Harpy eagles.
At the other extreme
is beta-diversity.
Of species that
are highly endemic,
what beta-diversity is-- it's
just a piece of eco jargon
that means the turnover
of species along gradients
or with distance.
And what you have
to do then is if you
have a high turnover of
species is to put reserves
in enough places where
they're distinct to protect
those populations.
So whether they're
chameleons in Madagascar
or highly-endangered parrots
in Colombia, bird wing
butterflies, or rare
plants, spacing the reserves
in the right places is critical.
That if we can capture this
pattern of turnover species
with distance and these vast
areas we need for conservation,
then we've pretty
much conserved 90%
of all species and processes.
And that's the crux of
conservation biology.
How that's playing
out is a new project
that we hope to involve
our colleagues at Google
with that's called
Nature Needs Half.
And Tanya said at the
end of my introduction
the Pope of
Conservation Biology,
E.O. Wilson, has come out
with a new book called
"Half Earth," which
calls for putting half
of the terrestrial realm
and half of the marine
under some form of
conservation management
if our species is
to survive and if we
are to save all the
other species on Earth.
So our approach of doing that
is to revisit a map that we
published in 2001 in the
"Journal of Bioscience"
called "Terrestrial Eco
Regions of the World,"
where we divide eco
regions not by countries--
not look at it by country,
but by eco regions.
And you can see how,
like here is Brazil.
The boundary here.
How eco region boundaries
or natures boundaries don't
follow political boundaries.
What we've done is to
apply this idea of nature
needs half to the
846 eco regions
that will be in this new
map called Eco Regions 2.0.
And to see how far we
are on our progress
of saving half of wild nature.
So we divide them
into four categories
of places that have already
exceeded 50% protection, places
that could do that, places
that with a lot of restoration
could do that, and
places that-- good luck,
its nature is really imperiled.
You know, the idea of taking the
Tallgrass Prairie of Illinois,
which is 99% soybeans
and corn would probably
require the end of
the civilized world
to ever get back
to nature in this.
So we're not being naive.
There are a lot of places--
not a lot of places
that can't do that.
But the surprising
and positive finding
is there are many eco
regions, perhaps a third
already, that either
have the ability
to protect-- that have already
protected half or close to it,
40%, or could do so.
So that it's not as
far-fetched as we think.
And so we're hoping
that this becomes,
really, the new conservation
paradigm of the next century.
That if we are to leave
behind a living planet,
we have to undertake
the exercises to plan--
to zone for
conservation and zone
for intensive human development
in the right places.
So that we leave space for the
tigers and rhinos and elephants
of Bardiya that I had the great
chance to study when I was 21.
And leave things for
future generations as well.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So for the
Nature Needs Half,
how much of the success there
is dependent on governments
buying into it?
ERIC DINERSTEIN:
So the question,
how much of Nature Needs
Half is getting governments
to buy into it?
Absolutely.
So one of the things we
talk about in the paper
is that almost every government,
except the United States
and Bhutan has signed on to
the Convention of Biodiversity.
And in that are a set of
targets that they're supposed
to reach by a certain date.
And so in this case,
they're codified
as the [? Ichee ?] targets.
And [? Ichee ?]
target 11 is aiming
for 17% of the terrestrial
realm conserved by 2020.
Right now, the global
amount is 15.4%.
We're trying to suggest that is
a really important and useful
milestone, but not
the end target.
Just because it's
nowhere near enough.
But governments have
bought into that.
So we're trying to
say, great milestone.
But over the next 10, 20, 30,
50 years, let's get to 50%.
But without the help
of the governments,
it won't be possible.
And however, the 50%
can also incorporate--
and will incorporate
indigenous reserves,
which are vast expanses of
some parts of the world.
Private reserves.
So there are other
ways that we can
get to 50% besides
just protected areas.
But that will be
certainly the cornerstone.
AUDIENCE: Let's say you take
an area and divide it in half.
And you have 50%
preserved, or conserved,
or managed in some way.
Now, let's say that you
take each of those halves
and divide it in half like
a checkerboard pattern.
And you keep doing that.
And eventually, you get a very
dispersed pattern that still
represents 50% of the area.
Which of those is better?
ERIC DINERSTEIN: Great question.
So what you've just
described is really
fragmentation of habitat.
And depending on where
you are-- so the answer,
like everything in
science, is it depends.
But in most cases, the more
connected, the more there
is habitat integrity,
the better the chances
are of conserving not
just the species there
that need big areas, but the
phenomenon that occur there
that drive the whole ecology.
So for example, if we were in
the Boreal Forest in Canada
right now, it's
these-- well, somebody
would call it cataclysmic,
but others would just
say extensive forest fires that
really drive those systems.
So your protected area
should be large enough
to contain either giant
insect outbreaks that
lead to a loss of trees or
these giant forest fires.
To be big enough to contain
those ecological events
and still persist.
And still recover.
For rain forest
versus grasslands,
like-- one of the things
we say in our paper
is that 50% is a
guideline, an aspirational.
But it's also not prescriptive.
It's an empirically-derived
estimate
that should come from studying
the biology of the species
in that eco region.
So to give you an example,
in a lot of rain forests
where you have very
high beta-diversity,
you want lots of
reserves spaced depending
on where the distributions
of those species are.
But in the Amazon
basin, there's estimates
that if we don't maintain
80% forest cover in those eco
regions, we lose the biophysical
function of the Amazon
as a weather machine
that makes its own rain.
Of how the rainfall that
comes off of the trade winds
gets recycled 10 times
before it hits the Andes,
and then moves back to provide
the precipitation for the corn
crop in South Africa or
the wheat crop in Canada.
A small part of it
makes its way back.
So there are some eco regions
that need a lot more area.
For some grasslands, because in
grasslands most of the species
there tend to be
pretty widespread,
it could be that a few whopping
big reserves would do better
than lots of small ones.
But in general, big
and well-connected
is better than small
and fragmented.
AUDIENCE: I was just curious on
the tigers and other predators.
Just curious on the
detail of, how do they
interact with other predators?
Do they need range separate
from other predators,
or do they kind of
not interact at all?
You know, wild dogs, and
leopards, and all that.
ERIC DINERSTEIN: So
they do interact.
And mostly, when you have a
top predator like a tiger,
the wild dogs and the leopards
try to stay away from them.
But leopards being much
smaller in body size,
they have much
smaller home ranges.
And wild dogs on the opposite
have enormous ranges.
Whether they're Asian
wild dogs, or they're
African painted
dogs or wild dogs,
they have gigantic ranges.
Because they're often
on the move and they're
hunting over big areas.
And probably, in part
they're trying to stay away
from the top predators.
So you see that phenomenon.
I mean, the wild dogs are
also different because they're
social hunters.
And they can take down, like the
sambar deer, when all of them
converge on a prey item.
So they can take things
much bigger than them.
Leopards, typically, don't
take prey bigger than
like, say, a sambar deer.
Some tigers are specialists
on killing things
like the Indian bison,
which is over 2,000 pounds.
So even though the
tigers are smaller,
they're very effective hunters.
TANYA: I find it very inspiring
and an incredible bright spot
that Nepal has not seen
an incident of poaching.
Is that something that
you think could be
replicated in other countries?
ERIC DINERSTEIN: Yes.
And it should be.
So in Nepal-- I've been
working there since 1975.
But it's taken years to
introduce new policies
and programs that the Nepalese
government, which really
is incredibly innovative
in a lot of ways,
has taken and run with.
One, for example, is we know
that we need to do conservation
outside the parks.
And we need to get local people
on our side for conservation
if it's to have
any lasting value.
They passed legislation
in the mid-90s to not only
hand over the forests
outside protected areas
to local communities
if they could come up
with good management
plans, but then
to recycle the revenue--
half the revenues generated
by the national parks
back to local communities
for development
for their own use,
if they come up
with good proposals.
And that's turned
people around the parks
who were anti-park before to
conservationists overnight.
And so in fact, why we
had the recovery of some
of those wildlife corridors
I showed between the parks
is because community forestry
programs are actively
protecting and monitoring
their own community forests.
And the wildlife is
coming back in them.
So that's been amazing.
The other thing
they do is they have
the army in the national parks.
And that acts as
a major deterrent.
That's problematic
in some countries.
But I think the biggest
difference is really
our successful anti-poaching
information network.
So intelligence is critical.
Back in the old days,
we would pay informants
more than the
poachers would get.
That's now leveled off a bit
with the value of rhino horn.
But still, the
transfer of revenues
from the parks themselves
back to communities
has given people an
investment in conserving
rhinos and tigers.
Such that, as I
say, there has not
been a single rhino,
tiger, or elephant
poached in three years.
And there's no other
country that can match that.
So clearly, Nepal is
doing something right.
Well, thank you very
much for your attention.
And--
TANYA: Thank you for
coming to Google.
[APPLAUSE]